it's unconscionable right now that we're
basically telling the poor world look we
got rich on fossil fuels it was great
for us but you know I'm sorry there's
not space for you so you just got to
stay poor and get used to it
hello and welcome to Marshall matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator on this show I speak to
heterodox thinkers on taboo topics and
today taboo topic is climate change the
apocalypse apparently is now flooding
heat waves fire Mother Nature is
striking we're Vengeance doomsdays tell
us constantly that we're reaching the
point of no return the unhcr claims
there are 20 million displaced people a
year owing to climate change and extreme
weather and uh Klaus Schwab founded the
world economic forum who are meeting
this month in Davos in his book The
Great narrative tries to build a whole
moral and values framework on the shared
belief that climate disaster is upon us
today I am joined by environmentalist uh
I should note skeptical environmentalist
Bjorn lombborg founder of the think tank
Copenhagen consensus and author of the
book false alarm how climate change
Panic costs us trillions hurts the poor
and fails to fix the planet Bjorn thank
you so much for taking the time
so uh in your book
you argue
green Pathways profit by
environmentalists such as the ipcc will
cause three million more deaths a year
than the fossil fuel pathway
it will see 26 million more extreme poor
every year and will cost a staggering
509 trillion dollars a year
that by quote insisting on cutting
carbon through climate
policies that push up food prices
instead of taking a broader view of how
to best help people and the planet we
will have consigned 54 million more
people to starvation
you're certainly a heterodox thinker
um and I'm Keen to get into all of that
but I was wondering if we could just
start with some really basic stuff
um so uh I've gone into the ipcc reports
and and I it strikes me and I think you
make this fairly clear in your book
false alarm that you do agree uh with
the ipcc which is the intergovernmental
panel on climate change the UN body you
do agree with their assessment that
since the end of the pre-industrial
period i 1880 the climate temperature
has risen by a mean of 0.85 degrees
Celsius and that it's anthropogenic by
man-made yes yes so fundamentally I
think it's actually 1.1 degrees so even
okay but yeah fundamentally yes global
warming is real it is mostly man-made uh
possibly all man-made as you just
pointed out and it is something that we
should consider how to fix so it's not a
conversation about is this man-made is
this a just a series or anything but
it's much more a conversation on on like
any other conversation we have in
politics
how much is this going to be of a
problem
and how much are our purported Solutions
gonna cost to fix how much of the issue
and the real Point here I think is to
recognize that when you're inundated
sometimes literally with all of this
information that tells you the end is
nigh
it sort of makes you believe well we
should spend whatever on it and remember
that's true if this was a meteor that's
one reason movie made it into if this
was a meteor hurtling towards Earth
we should have no other issue you know
focusing on us if this is going to kill
everyone on Earth obviously this is our
biggest and only real thing that we
should be concerned about it is not and
that's not what the U.N climate panel
tells us it's not what the best economic
model tells us they tell us this is
going to be a problem not the end of the
world now if it's a problem and the way
you could compare it is perhaps a little
bit like a chronic disease like you know
diabetes it's certainly something you'd
prefer not to have but it is also
something that you can live with and
that you should live with you should
take some precautions you should take
your medications you should change your
diet but you should also recognize this
is absolutely livable with so that
changes very much the kind of way that
you think about climate so it's a
problem not the end of the world and we
should make smart policies but not as
we're doing right now an enormous amount
of policies that are very costly and
actually do very little good well I'm
Keen to get into those specific policies
and your alternative policies but one
thing that uh just if we can stick on
basics for one more moment and it the
the the Doomsday is that we've both
cited uh you and them are sort of both
drawing from the apc's ipcc reports and
uh and the it it seems to me that you're
choosing different and rcps which are
these models for how we project the
environment crisis or change rather to
unfold and you're both drawing from the
same information but coming with very
different attitudes so what am I not
understanding what is the representative
concentration Pathways so that's
basically a question of how much
emissions are we going to have over the
21st century and so the very high
numbers the 8.5 as a as sort of a world
Runner Mark uh uh just totally powered
by Coal fire power plants sort of five
times as much coal as what we're using
now very unlikely scenario the uh uh 2.6
is a very low scenario where we will
basically become all environmentalist in
a very short while also fairly
unrealistic and so the most realistic
outcome is is the 4.5 and as you can
just hear most of our listeners probably
oh I almost glaze over my eyes right
because it's a very unhelpful way of of
it's a very you know sort of a
technocratic way of of defining it but
it matters in the sense that if we're
actually going to emit lots and lots of
uh CO2 that will make the problem bigger
if we're going to emit almost no CO2 of
course there's not going to be much of a
problem the honest answer is we'll
probably emit somewhere in between and
that's a problem again not the end of
the world but so I don't think it's I
mean I agree that you sort of glaze over
it when you're reading it it's kind of
tricky but if you see it as one extreme
on one side one extreme in the other in
the middle but why why I don't quite get
is that let's say the UN all these
people meeting in Davos they very much
believe in the extreme and they're
preaching the extreme
uh but you're but you're not and why
have you chosen okay yes the specific
RCP that is different from them
so I'm I'm not sure I really choose them
all that much and I'll get back to that
in just a second uh but almost all the
evidence now shows that the very high so
the 8.5 RC uh RCP is just not
plausible it's possibly not even doable
so it's it is just a scare scenario now
there's a lot of reasons why a lot of uh
modelers use it uh you know if if you're
gonna find out whether something gives
you a cancer you'll typically give it to
rats and then you give it in huge doses
because the idea is if we give it a few
little doses like most humans have you
almost can't see it so you need like a
hundred thousand rats to see if there's
a slightly more cancer whereas if you
just stuff them with the stuff you know
they'll it'll show up in just 10 or a
hundred uh rats and it's a little bit
the same kind of thing that you do with
the environmental system so you pump it
with the 8.5 then you more easily see
the impacts that makes perfect
scientific sense but what then happens
is then and yeah it's sort of very
obvious that then you come out and say
oh this is going to rise sea levels
enormously and then the newspapers of
course come out and say all right so
there's a study there that says you know
sea levels are going to rise a little
bit it and there's a study there that
says it's going to rise a huge bit what
are we going to pick we're obviously
going to highlight the the one that's
most alarmist because it just makes for
the best headlines it doesn't mean it's
a good description of what's going to
happen so that's one part of it but but
but but but to be quite Frank that's not
the main point that I really try to push
so that was my other argument I'm not
really all that and engaged in in is it
RCP uh be 4.5 or 8.5 it's much more the
fact that most of these predictions that
you hear almost everywhere in the Press
do not take into account the humans
change their behavior so they
fundamentally look at climate change
which is absolutely true and this is
because of climate uh this because of
Human Action but they don't take into
account that humans change according to
that so take for instance sea level rise
when silos if we take a fairly high
level estimate so that would be almost
8.5 that's certainly some of the things
I quote uh of about a meter of sea level
rise over this Century which would be a
significant impact the simple way of
looking at that is to say all right if
nothing else happens what will happen
with a one meter sea level rise oh
London is going to be underwater lots of
other places are going to be underwater
much of Netherlands are going to be
underwater because they didn't update
their dikes that is going to be
phenomenally costly so you can basically
make a model that says if nobody changes
their attitude
this is going to flood large parts of
the world and so you know one study that
got headlined in New York Times in
Washington Post many other places tell
you that you will see 187 million people
flooded so they'll have to move or you
know Rolling Stones even said they'll
drown which of course doesn't happen
over 100 years that you'll you'll
actually get out of the water uh but
also it'll have huge costs so uh
somewhere between 55 and 100 trillion
dollars per year in cost now this is all
true if we were stupid enough to not do
anything for the next 80 years of course
we're not that kind of people we
actually see all right sea levels rise
we build higher dikes we make more
infrastructure not vulnerable to uh to
to sea level rise we know how to do that
and Holland again of course is a great
example of how to do that if you assume
that people act as they've done before
and it's important to say this was
actually in the models that said the 187
million that got the headlines in New
York Post and Washington Post they say
this is an implausible argument to
assume that people won't act if they act
we estimate instead of seeing 180 uh 87
000 more people uh being flooded we see
many many fewer people being flooded
actually we'll go right now it's about
3.4 million people being flooded every
year instead of going up it'll go down
to about 15 000 people being flooded why
because we're richer and hence much much
more resilient this is you know this
blows the minds of most climate you know
campaigners because that obviously you
think if sea levels are going to rise
then clearly we're going to be in more
trouble and that's true we will be more
trouble than if the sea levels hadn't
risen
but as we also get much richer we
actually know how to deal with that so
we will reduce our level of
vulnerability by the end of the century
we will because of sea level rise have
about 15 000 people being flooded this
is one very very quota model
if we had had no climate impact
it would only have been ten thousand so
you know climate really still does play
an impact it actually you know increases
the number of people flooded by 50 but
it's a trivial number compared to what
it is today and of course it's an
absolutely trivial number compared to
what scare stories tell us so if you
only tell one part of the story if you
only tell sea levels rise nobody else
does anything the world is screwed that
that makes sense but that's not the
correct story that's not a politically
informative story because that's not the
world we live in we live in a world
where because we're richer we'll
actually deal with many of these issues
and yes we'll still have a residual
problem of 15 000 people being floated
every year that's still a problem it's a
much better world than one where 3.4
million people who flood every year and
certainly much much better than what we
you know read in New York Times and
Washington post about 187 million people
being flooded but I understand why New
York Times and Washington Post made that
story because it's much more fun to read
and it sells yeah it gets clickbait but
so this has got powerful because through
your book you keep saying climate change
is bad you insist that climate change is
bad yes and and you've made this example
here like climate change human cause
climate change will increase sea levels
uh but I came away from the book almost
feeling like climate change isn't so bad
because you're so hopeful of of these
invasions uh human ability to adapt and
and you insist on adaptation is an
important thing for us to concentrate
our energy on but I wondered if we could
just identify a couple of the the bad
things I've also noticed in your in your
uh interviews you tend to there's a lot
of sort of
explaining why the alarmism is is wrong
but but given that you insist that
climate change is bad what are the what
are the other problems of climate change
so so and and this is what's so hard
when you try to think of the world from
an economist point of view so
fundamentally what you see and uh you
know look if we just take a look at
temperature
as temperatures rise you're going to get
more heat waves you're going to get more
problems with heat and you're going to
get fewer problems with cold if you look
at two cities like Helsinki and Athens
they're both very well adapted to what
their temperatures used to be if we
increase the temperature for both of
them which is what climate change does
or indeed if had gone down if you know
sort of global cooling kind of thing was
happening both of those things would be
bad for both of those cities because
they've invested an enormous amount of
money and resources into buildings in
Helsinki that are really warm in the
winter and in Athens you know that are
really cool in summer
if you change the temperature it will
change the optimization of that of both
those cities so you know both Helsinki
and Athens will have to invest more in
air conditioning and less in heating
that's going to cost them money that's
going to be Troublesome this is the
basic problem of climate change this is
why all economists will tell you when
you have an equilibrium a very very
large Investments typically of stock so
you know buildings and Industry and that
kind of thing when when the
circumstances change that will have a
cost it is not this huge cost that our
climate campaigners would like us to
believe but it's a cost nonetheless so
the economist will tend to tell you that
by the end of the century so this is the
work of Nord house uh William nordhaus
the only climate Economist to ever win
the Nobel Prize in climate economics in
2018 from Yale University and what he
tells us is that if we do nothing about
climate by the end of the century it
will mean that we will be about four
percent less well-off than we otherwise
would now remember a lot of the impacts
on climate change are not actually going
to be economic impact is going to be the
fact that you know some of our Wetlands
will suffer uh you'll have uh you know
you'll have to have uh more air
conditioning in in summer heat waves
that kind of thing but it will feel like
and that's how economists do it it'll
feel like you're four percent less
well-off now at the same time the UN
estimate the average person on the
planet because we have seen sustained
economic growth over the last 200 years
by the end of the century the average
person on the planet will be 450 as rich
as what he or she is today so we'll be
much richer the four percent reduction
means that essentially by the end of the
century if we do nothing about climate
instead of being 450 as Rich we will
only be 434 percent as rich and this
explains I think your your sort of
conundrum because what it means is it's
obviously a less good world where we're
only 434 percent as Rich compared to a
world where we're 450 and and just
remember these all model estimates I
mean they're they're not true numbers
but they're order magnitude numbers so
it's obviously a less good world but
it's still a pretty damn good world
where we're 434 percent as rich and that
goes to show you that climate change is
a real problem and that's mostly because
it affects all of our stock decisions so
everything we've already built will be
slightly out of optimum and that will
have cost but it's cost of you know the
order of four percent in total compared
to the fact that by the end of the
century will be uh you know 450 percent
of 434 percent as rich as where now that
is why you come away with these sets of
but it's not that big a problem exactly
it is one of the many problems we need
to fix but it's not the end of all and
that's of course why this is not the
media hurtling towards Earth this is one
of the many you know nagging issues that
we'll have to fix in the 21st century so
climate policy is a a trade-off then in
how much climate change will affect GDP
compared to how much it otherwise uh a
policy can can this is this is
essentially what nordhaus got the Nobel
Prize for he said and you know to any
Economist that's sort of obvious but but
it's not to a lot of other people
fundamentally climate has costs and
that's what you hear constantly and
that's typically vastly exaggerated
right so you hear about the sea level
rise you don't hear that it costs about
30 billion dollars which is probably the
right answer but you hear that it costs
50 55 trillion dollars so you you get it
you know sort of what's three orders of
magnitude wrong it's more than a
thousand times bigger that's why it
makes big headlines so you get the sense
that this is the end of the world kind
of thing but you also have to remember
that climate policy has cost so when you
make climate policy you it you by Design
make for instance energy more expensive
because you have to switch to energy
that you wouldn't otherwise have done
which is typically either more costly or
a combination of less
reliable or less available so
fundamentally we're saying you have a
cost then you try to make a climate
policy which also has a cost given that
we have to pay both of these costs we
should make sure that we minimize the
sum of these two so an economist that's
an obvious way of saying we want to make
the system such that everybody are best
off in 2100 but to many people there's a
sense of the costs are incredibly
exaggerated and there's virtually no
cost to the policies actually they'll
make better off that's what a lot of
people will tell you while at the same
time of course they also tell you yeah
this is going to be incredibly hard and
very very costly so we need to subsidize
everyone and all these kinds of
complicated ways and it's going to be
really hard to get most of the
developing countries along with this and
all these other things which sort of
gives away yes this is going to be
fantastically costly just to give you
one ballpark figure uh the McKinsey
estimate on on Net Zero estimate that
this is going to cost to to get to Net
Zero in the smart way will cost the
world in the order of uh six trillion
dollars per year for the next 30 Years
uh and you know of course that's six
trillion dollars that's more than the
entire education system the entire world
it's it's a very very large number of
money do you think so let's look at the
policies then let's start with Net Zero
since you've brought that up is
okay aside from how expensive it is with
uh is there any value in in is it a
policy that you completely throw out or
or is there anything about it which you
you value of course I value I mean look
CO2 is a problem if you come up with a
policy that says we're going to get rid
of all CO2 emissions that's a good so
you know NetZero is a policy that tries
to do some good in the UK given that UK
is about what one percent Global
emissions you're basically saying we're
going to try to cut Global emissions by
one percent by 2050. that's a good thing
that's you know it's better that it's 99
that it's a hundred percent
but the point is it is going to have a
minuscule impact uh I I can pretty well
assure you that you know if you if you
draw this with a pencil the temperature
line with without the UK's policy and
with the UK's policy you can't tell the
difference you need to sharpen your
pencil a lot before you can tell the
difference between those two lines so
fundamentally you're making a policy
that will have virtually no impact on
the global scale now if it will cost it
will cost
then maybe we should do it yeah so the
point is it does do some good
but if it's going to be fantastically
costly not and I think this is important
to uh to point out not only will it mean
that it's a really bad policy to do you
know that you're basically saying let's
spend lots and lots of resources to
achieve a little tiny bit of good that's
a very bad deal but also if you try to
do that it is inevitable that you will
get a revolution sooner or later right
you will get people voting for Donald
Trump or bolsonaro or some people like
that who say why the hell I don't know
if we can say these words on on your
podcast I just did sorry so you'll have
to believe it but anyway why are we
paying all this money instead of just
taking for ourselves you we saw this in
France yeah yeah so you'll basically get
people to stop way before uh you're
there so uh one nature study showed uh
so a reason in in the nature Journal uh
indicated that the cost of almost
reaching Joe Biden's policy by 2050 is
equivalent to costing each American
every year by 2050 uh more than 11 000
per person per year this is just you
know remember it they'll be richer it's
not the end of the world it's about you
know what 11 of their income so that's a
lot of money but it's not the end of the
world these Americans will still be okay
off but I I defy you to believe that
most people are still going to be voting
for someone who says you know what I'm
gonna make you bleed eleven thousand
dollars every year they're just not
going to do that and of course this is
Rich World policy sees imagine asking
and that's one of the things I thought
was amazing about the McKinsey study
they actually showed that for India for
instance you'd have to spend about 10
percent of their GDP on Net Zero policy
that that's just implausible to imagine
that you know up and coming fairly poor
you know still lower income uh uh Low
Middle income country that they're going
to be willing to spend 10 of their GDP
actually spending on GDP on on on Net
Zero globally would cost somewhere
between half and two-thirds of the
entire Global Tax intake that we have
from all nations in the world every year
that's just not impo that's impossible
so you can say you want to do it it's a
bad idea but it's also a bad idea in the
sense that we know once you start
implementing people are just going to
vote you out of all can I ask them about
the Paris agreement because that's also
sort of the standard now that everyone
refers to and and but you rile against
it and and you're very crazy I hope I'm
not riling because I that sound make me
sound unreasonable I'm just simply
saying it's a reasonable writing yes
you're very critical of of the the Paris
agreement in that I think you say will
cost us a TR a trillion dollars uh a
year by 2030 yes to to implement with
little gain yes yes so actually because
we've we just talked about a much much
Dumber policy which is net zero uh so in
that context Paris agreement is only a
semi-dumb uh policy that's that's why I
probably also uh you know uh it's the
one that we've actually decided to do so
yes it's still dumb and we shouldn't do
it uh I estimate that whereas the
benefit cost ratio for Net Zero is
probably you know about one pence back
on the on the pound or one cent back in
the dollar
um uh Paris agreement might make us 10
cents back in the dollar which is you
know it's ten times better but it's
still like you could have you could just
have given that dollar away and done the
world ten times more good so it's still
a dumb policy but it's a list on policy
and again we need to have this
conversation not because we are so
focused on saying this is the end of the
war because if it is the end of world
again then it doesn't make sense you
know AOC was famously quoted
um back in 2018 where where she said we
only have 12 years late uh left uh for
the world which makes sense if you read
some of the documents especially how
they were put out but what she what she
said and I think that makes perfect
sense I totally understand her she said
the world is ending and you're asking
how much will it cost to fix it that
makes perfect sense if it is the end of
the world we should just spend
everything how when you say it makes
sense by what she read yes what would
you mean what did she read that made
sense so she read the the 12 years is uh
so in 2018 or actually a couple years
before that uh we asked the so all World
politicians asked the U.N climate panel
eipc uh to do a report on what would it
take to get to 1.5 degrees Centigrade so
limit Global temperature rise to 1 1.5
degrees right this is going to be
incredibly hard I think most people sort
of privately would accept this is just
not possible but yeah so what the report
came out and said all right you've asked
us what will it take to do something
that's almost impossible and our answer
is it'll be almost impossible it'll
basically take that we have to change
the entire world fundamentally
before 2030. and that was the 12 years
that's where the 12 years come from so
basically they say if you ask us to do
almost impossible stuff you have to do
almost impossible stuff to achieve it
which is technically true but you know
that doesn't mean the world is ending in
12 years but I think she gets and I
think a lot of people get when you read
the media and if this is not you know
most people have other things to do then
read the U.N climate panel report and
they actually have kids to pick up from
school that kind of thing if you need to
do that
your only reasonable estimate is that
yeah this sounds like a terrible deal
this really sounds like the meteor
hurtling towards Earth and then sure you
know spend all my money on on avoiding
that that's not where we're on that's
why this this is an important
conversation and that's based on the 1.5
degree celsius which you say is an in
your book is an arbitrary number oh it's
it's an arbitrary number I mean you can
tell from the fact that it doesn't have
any more digits it's just yeah and and
even two degrees cert Target which was a
much more prevalent uh uh uh uh Target
is also just an arbitrary Target it's
something that you know people came up
with there's there's one set of stories
it's very very hard to sort of tell the
the starting point actually there's some
some legitimacy to the fact that it that
it started from one of nordhaus papers a
guy who won the Nobel Prize in climate
economics uh that it started back uh in
the 1980s where he estimated uh what was
the maximum temperature that some weeds
could survive on a on a riverbed uh and
it and and that research said that they
could probably not handle more than
about a 0.2 degree temperature rise per
decade which turns into the two degree
Target but it's that kind of level of
thing yeah it's a it's a it's a it's a
thing you you stick your finger in the
air and say you know that sounds like a
reasonable number and of course that's
not how we should set uh policy targets
for one of the most costly and
potentially most impactful policies but
you know surely we should actually ask
what are the cost what are the benefits
right okay I see and and so can we go
back then seeing as on on policy that
how you've come let's say to the rather
uh potentially climate alarmist alarmist
statement that uh the the the the uh
three million more deaths a year uh will
happen if we take the green pathway
rather than the fossil fuel pathway so
this is this is more sort of a it's not
something I'm gonna I'll go out on a
limb to defend because that was not my
main point in the book it was it was
more a point of saying so the UN has
made some a number of different uh
scenarios for what the world looked like
which is necessary because we actually
have to talk about how much CO2 do
different civilizations emit in all the
years out to 2100 in order to be able to
run the models so one of their models is
the standard model that was the one I
was referring to the ssp2 uh the middle
of the road model if you will uh which
is the one that give 450 richer by the
end of the century then there are two
pretty bad scenarios I'm not going to go
into those and then there are two good
scenarios if you will one of them is the
green scenario which you would imagine
that sounds like a really nice scenario
we actually get richer than in the
middle of the road scenario uh we live
longer lives we're better educated
crucially of course coming to the green
we emit a lot less CO2 it's a nicer more
beautiful world in all kinds of ways the
that sounds like the one we would like
right but there's another one that's
called the fossil fuel intensive way
which is basically we just go crazy on
on putting out lots and lots of fossil
fuels we just power the entire world
with lots of power everybody gets lots
of power that doesn't sound very nice
and I think most people would sort of
intuitively say oh
we shouldn't be doing that however it
turns out
that we would be twice as Rich by the
end of the century we would have lifted
many more people out of poverty that was
one of the points that you made we would
have so many more resources that even
though the climate change would
obviously be a worse outcome because
we'd be pumping out more CO2 in the
atmosphere we would be way better off so
we would actually leave our descent much
much better off by focusing on that
fossil fuel path now I'm not saying we
should take that I think that this this
is too much money but it's too much of a
scenario conversation but I think it's
it should get us to think about the fact
that we constantly think in our in our
way sort of you know for for for how we
have a policy conversation we think
about greeners just being a good thing
but if there's a huge trade-off on
pretty much everything else you also
want education uh Liberty of women uh
getting people out of poverty having the
opportunity to do pretty much everything
you will be much more resilient those
kinds of things maybe we should at least
think about the fact that green is not
the only thing we want that's the
trade-off I wanted out with that quote
and so with the the 26 million more
extreme poor sort of be in that same
category of the extreme and and look we
we're in advanced civilization we can
walk into gum at the same time we can
actually both be somewhat green and very
rich and I think that's what everyone
would want to do that's why I'm I'm not
I'm loathed to just say you know the UN
mapped out five ways for the future you
can only choose one of those five that's
that's a little silly uh way of thinking
about the world I just wanted to make
sure that you understand that it's not
just such that the green World sounds
like really good because the dirty world
if you will is actually much much better
in their scenario but what we obviously
should be aiming for is one where we're
both incredibly Rich where we really
focus on lifting people out of poverty
and making sure we have lots of
productivity and become green and it's
curious if you actually look at the
evidence where are pollution problems
they're not mostly in the rich world
they're in the poor World India gandu uh
one of the first prime ministers in of
India she said you know the real power
the real source of pollution is poverty
now if you're poor you cut down
rainforest you'll do anything to make
your kids survive right but if you're
rich you actually care about the
environment because you can afford to
because you no longer have to worry
about where your next meal come from so
you're focusing if we lift the poor out
of poverty that is the the correct way
to to uh one of the ways look there
there's many different objectives in the
world I'm sorry I I can't I I should see
in your face you'd like me to just say
yes or no no no no no but but you know
fundamentally uh it's one of the many
things that we need to do we should lift
people out of poverty I think it's
unconscionable right now that we're
basically telling the poor world look we
got rich on fossil fuels it was great
for us but you know I'm sorry there's
not space for you so you just gotta stay
poor and get used to it that just
doesn't work and of course they're not
going to accept that either but I think
that's you know unconscionable in any
kind of way uh but likewise we obviously
also need to fix a lot of environmental
problems and there's lots of air
pollution around the world and India go
to India they clearly need to clean up a
lot of that will come as they get richer
but we can also help with more
technology and of course we also need to
fix climate change but one of the truths
that we forget when we're so worried
about climate because we hear all these
scary messages is what solves most
problems is not making people scared and
it's not selling people you have to do
without because that never works what
works is you have technological
innovation let me just tell you a story
that sounds like it's totally irrelevant
but back in 1860s
uh the world caught almost all the
whales it gets it hands on and you know
we were basically getting close to being
able to wipe out the whales why because
they produce this oil that burns
incredibly cleanly and very brightly so
basically lit up most of Western Europe
and North America
everybody loved it now if you were sort
of a standard climate person trying to
get people to stop killing all the
whales you'd be saying stop doing that
you got to go back to that dirty old you
know less luminous but much more
polluting uh uh fuel to light your
houses and people would say huh not
gonna do that what actually did work was
we discovered oil and oil happens to be
a lot easier to get out of ground than
actually going out in the ocean surface
to kill a whale and just get a little
bit of blubber so it was a much better
much more effective way and suddenly
everybody just switched to oil and we
basically saved the whales it's not the
only thing and there's a lot of other
you know nuances to the story but the
fundamental Point here is if you have
innovation you can get good stuff
without having to tell people you have
to do with less and I think that's what
we're struggling with right now with
climate conversation it's become about
this you've got to you know eat less
you've got to travel less you've got to
you know be a little colder a little
poorer it's going to be a little more
uncomfortable but at least we'll save
the planet most people are just not
going to say yes to that and certainly
not in Africa and India elsewhere what
we will solve the climate crisis with or
I'm not going to say climate crisis the
climate problem
is by focusing on Innovation imagine if
we could innovate say fourth generation
nuclear to be cheaper than fossil fuels
yeah and everyone would switch you
wouldn't
Grant meetings in Paris and everywhere
else you just simply see Nations across
the world switch so on that and it is
that's a question of levelized energy
cost and Innovation combined but so I'd
have thought so if you're taking it the
issues as if you just focus on energy
where we get our energy from and and
correct me if I get any of this wrong
because uh new to the relatively new to
this but uh that's where the sort of uh
greenhouse gases is coming from uh then
I'd have thought that innovation in wind
and solar would be a a sensible Way
Forward now I understand that the
problem we've got is storage we can't
store it but we need innovation in
storage but in your book and this would
by the way this ties in with your
example of of the whales like uh we we
found a better fuel and so we moved off
naturally now if wind and solar is way
cheaper and it's infinitely better for
the environment than the other the other
um energy uh options we have and yet you
write in your book rolling out solar
solar panels and wind turbines have
Insidious effects they push up energy
costs hurt the poor cut emissions
inefficient and effectually and put
unsustainable Pathways where taxpayers
are eventually likely to revolt so why
are you against solar and wind isn't
that the new version of moving from the
whale to it could definitely be so I'm
I'm not against that solar and wind
could be a solution in the long run but
right now now there are only a tiny bit
of solution so there's actually some you
know let me just start with a positive
if you look for instance in the
California where the peak electricity
use is in the daytime it makes a lot of
sense to have solar panels because that
can actually cut the peak level you know
solar panels not surprisingly Peak at
the middle of the day and typically if
they Peak because of air conditioning
use so they'll only Peak when you need
when the sun is out so it actually fits
perfectly you should have solar panels
for that
but the point is that most people seem
to believe that we should somehow
blanket the world with solar power or
wind turbines and that will provide us
energy and there the problem is no
that's going to be fantastically costly
and you need almost the entire stock of
fossil fuel options as backup because
right now we don't have batteries and we
have no sense of how we could have
enough batteries to actually have
storage enough uh so right now the world
has battery storage for about one minute
and 15 seconds uh so when we're you know
when the sun shuts down and the wind
stops blowing you have enough battery
power to keep the world running for one
minute and 15 seconds and after that
you're back to fossil fuels by 2030
it'll be up to 11 minutes that's still
way less than what you need so in
Germany every year they have so so
little sun and no wind for at least five
days or the equivalent of about 7 000
minutes so we're far far away so my
point is but that's battery right so
what about hydrogen or water storage so
yeah are those not better options so
water storage is a good idea and we've
we actually have a lot of it but it's
really hard to imagine that you can have
it many more places than you already
have because it's very very uh uh
feature dependent so basically it
requires you to live in a place where
close by you have lots and lots of
mountains where you can pump up water
that can stay there so it has to be a
reservoir some places you can do it
that's a really cheap way of storing and
you should definitely do it we've done
most of that uh the hydrogen turns out
to be very inefficient pretty dangerous
it could be a solution so again I'm
arguing and if you've seen a book I
definitely say spend more money on
getting better uh wind turbines spend
more more money on it on Innovation on
getting better solar panels absolutely
spend a lot of different ways to get
better storage but it doesn't seem like
at the current rate that this is what's
going to save most of the issue so it's
it's at best one of those things where
we should also be focusing and we'll
solve a little bit of the problem
through that but in in the current
conversation and climate it's almost
become the you know the savior of
everything you know we should just have
much more soul and much more wind and
people routinely talk talk about the
fact that yeah then we'll have you know
like six times as much wind and three
times is more uh as much solar and then
we will do hydrogens as backup and stuff
like that that's all fine but then of
course you can't claim that the one time
is efficient because the the next five
times are credibly ineffective right so
you need to do the math again and we
don't we just you know we just sort of
proceed on uh on a prayer and a hope I'm
wasting a lot of money and yes so in
amongst your solutions for uh climate
change uh some of which we've already
discussed like Innovation adaptation but
carbon tax
you believe in carbon tax but wouldn't
like the other uh policies we've
discussed being the problematic policies
wouldn't that also hurt the poor
wouldn't it be the poor who end up
paying more for energy they're already
paying a higher percentage of of their
income on energy carbon tax is just
going to mean that that goes up yes how
can you support carbon tax but be
against these other sorry so it's it's
important to say when you talk to an
economist you'll typically just hear
about efficiency so uh Equity so the
distribution is a different issue uh now
clearly if you actually do a carbon tax
so the point I make with the carbon
taxes as as I think all climate
economists and pretty much all
economists what are here is to say
that's the right way to fix the problem
now there's two main issues with it one
is it's very hard to convince
politicians is a good idea because they
they'll likely get bumped out of of
office by trying to do this and secondly
if you do a carbon tax you also have to
scrap all the subsidies that you have
for everything else right you can't both
have a tax and all these subsidies
that's incredible an effective way but
that's unfortunately very often how you
end up now if you do the carbon tax
right you get a lot of extra Revenue
that's sort of in line with how we think
generally about you need some Revenue to
run a state and there's ineffective ways
of doing that that's for instance income
tax vat lots of other ways that are
fairly destructive or distortive in the
economy and it turns out that a carbon
tax is one of the least distortive taxes
so you could fund more the state with a
carbon tax and that means you could give
back either by
lowering the income tax or perhaps just
give money back directly to poor people
you know that's the uh the the check
idea that a lot of people have that you
actually send out to poor people so
there's a lot of ways you can address
this I think it is also important to say
that a lot of people who are skeptical
about attacks and I I get that point is
that have we ever actually seen
politicians say you know what we got two
much tax in we're going to lower some of
the other taxes so there's a real worry
that it's just going to lead to higher
taxes which of course just means more
Distortion instead of less so so yeah
it's a it's a in theory correct
a solution I think we should definitely
consider it but we also need to know all
the things that it entails so I want to
ask a question that I I hear a lot from
uh the the people purporting that this
the the the the end of the world is is
coming and it's sort of anti-natalist
attitude that the world cannot hold more
as many people as we currently hold and
we certainly can't can't grow do you do
you agree with this or do you think we
have the ability to
um uh does the globe have the Earth have
a higher capacity for human population
than we're currently at so it's a it's a
it's a very very large question I don't
think I'm going to give you a satisfying
answer to this so the short point is of
course more people means more CO2
emissions so they have a point in saying
that maybe if we were fewer people that
would be better for the planet in the
sense that we would have less carbon
emissions but it's a very very specific
and very narrow way of looking at the
issue because obviously if we have more
people in the planet we also have more
Geniuses we'll have more people that'll
you know discover the cure for cancer
and we'll have more mozarts and all this
other stuff so fundamentally We are
failing to capture all the benefits of
having people now uh most people uh make
very clear choices where they choose to
live most people don't actually live
where there are few people yeah there's
lots of Countryside where you can go up
uh and and and live pretty well most
people actually pay exorbitant rents to
be able to live in you know downtown New
York uh where you have a crappy little
apartment at huge cost but because it's
so much fun to live together with other
people and so in some sense it seems
like we're actually voting when you ask
people with our feet to mostly live
where everybody else lives so we
actually like to congregate I think
these are much much grander
conversations and we can reasonably have
it's also important to say that it sort
of touches some of the basic human
freedoms you know to many people having
a child or having more children is one
of the most important things a more most
meaningful things they can do with their
lives and I think it's a terrible idea
to go and and say you shouldn't do that
on the other hand we should also
recognize that you know if you have lots
and lots of kids and you don't have much
productive capacity maybe it leaves you
in a bad in a worse place uh so I'm much
more agnostic to this kind of
conversation I think you need to make
sure that people have the opportunity to
have contraception for instance we know
a lot of women that actually get more
kids than they want especially in a
developing world
and and and uh getting especially women
more education also and more business
opportunities also means that they're
gonna decide to have many fewer kids
because they're going to say I would
like to actually make my own career and
I'd like to have my own job and do my
own impact on on the world in many other
ways and that probably is a good thing
overall now uh so so the short answer is
just to look at this as a climate
solution it's a terrible way to look at
it because basically you end up telling
people you know what you would probably
get the most meaning out of having a kid
but no yeah and that's just terrible
look what we should do is innovation to
make sure that we fix climate change and
then the question of how many people
should we be as a separate problem
there's also always that thing when you
talk to people who are advocating we're
too many people it's often you know too
many of you but just enough of me yeah
and that obviously comes across as a
little hypocritical I you know there's a
lot of these people who will tell you
there's too many people on the planet
but they certainly don't have problem
with their own kids I I think we're on
really sketchy uh sort of moral
territory yeah and it's tied in
potentially too big a topic for now but
I mentioned this in the introduction is
that the unhcr say there are 20 million
displaced people a year because of
climate and extreme weather and it is
it's a it's a fact or a statement that
is often cited by
um in environmental alarmists and what's
your take on that do you think so there
is a reasonable uh the problem was you
know the problem with uh environmental
refugees and climate refugees is that
it's almost all rubber band you know you
can you can choose to Define any of
these in any kind of ways so what they
cleverly do is say it's climate and
weather related uh uh uh uh refugees and
of course you know weather does uh you
know uh uh push a lot of people away
from where they usually would live uh if
we look at the recent floods in Pakistan
that a lot of people have been sort of
blaming on climate that has some
reasonability there is some truth to the
fact that we would expect in a warmer
climate that you would have more
precipitation therefore also have more
risk of of flooding but of course the
real point is that Pakistan for what 20
30 40 years have ignored to make their
infrastructure better for water get more
uh uh what are features that you
actually Safeguard your uh your main uh
economic centers that you make sure
people don't build and especially live
on places that will get flooded you know
these are basic things and so in our
effort to focus on a climate solution
which just remember even if we actually
did all of what we promised with Net
Zero would mean that Pakistan would be
slightly less more inundated by the end
of the century that's a terribly low bar
to try to help Pakistan with instead of
saying well why don't we actually try to
focus on getting them politically better
able to deal with these issues so they
need to invest more in their uh water
infrastructure they need to have more uh
boundaries where people can't settle and
of course we need to get them out of
poverty because if you're not in poverty
you actually fix most of these problems
as Holland has shown you so the point
here is to say in some ways I get that
many of these environmental active
twists are you know they come from a
good place they want to help the world
but they're unfortunately advocating
possibly the least effective way to help
so they're saying let's do the thing
that'll cost them worth money that'll
make most people unhappy and unlikely to
happen but even if it did it'll actually
help terribly terribly little instead of
and that's what my Think Tank then does
and a lot of different things there's a
lot of simple things where we could
actually have huge impact at very low
cost why don't we do those first
um so uh last thing I want to ask you
about is something you've been writing
about recently and I believe you're
working on this with your Think Tank
which is the un's sdg sustainable
development goals and uh you have
identified various problems with the the
program and the goals and as one of you
could explain what an sdg is exactly and
and what's wrong and what's going wrong
with it yeah so it's it's sort of a a
neat follow-on from our home
conversation and climate because what my
think tank does and I think what we all
should be doing in all kinds of walks of
life is simply to say everything you
choose has a cost and a benefit why
don't we do the things that cost little
and have huge benefits first you know so
it's not rocket science we do this in
our own lives all the time why don't we
do this in our political lives as well
why don't we do this as Nations well a
lot of it is because there's a lot of
campaigning going on for some things so
you know we worry a lot about Plastics
in the ocean which I think is is a nice
thing to worry about but you know come
on shouldn't we worry more about the
fact that diesel cars pollute the
atmosphere for my kids to die right now
I mean it seems like that would be
slightly bigger issue but it's not
because you know the plastic in the
ocean feels like a much better again so
what we try to do is basically say where
can you get the most value for your
money what is the smartest policies to
do the sdg sustainable development goals
is the UN so it's really all countries
of the UK the US everybody has signed up
to this except for Syria and one other
country I can't remember so you know
fundamentally everyone in the world has
signed up to this it's a promise to do a
lot of good things by 2030. so we
promised fundamentally to do all good
things so we promised to eradicate War
eradicate disease eradicate hunger get
rid of global warming uh get everybody
educated well and all the other things
you can think of down to get more
Recycling and have more parks for
handicapped people in bigger cities and
the whole shebang right so we basically
promise everything we already said back
then you know when we promised that you
can't just promise everything if you
promise everything it's like having no
priorities and you're not going to make
any of it we're not half time for this
process and we're nowhere near halfway
our promises which is not surprising so
what we're saying is look if you can't
do it all shouldn't we do the smartest
things first so we try to identify just
like in climate what are the smartest
policies so climate the smartest policy
by far is to invest in Innovation if you
can come up with great new innovations
that will make clean available
green energy cheaper than fossil fuels
everyone will switch so that's the
solution for climate that's a pretty
good investment it's not a fantastic
investment but it's pretty good good
investment but if you look at some of
the things you could do for the world
and let me just give you a few tastes so
we have like 12 amazing policies the
world should be focused on tuberculosis
so we worried a lot about covet these
last two years but in 2022
tuberculosis was back again as the
world's leading infectious disease
killer wow and it yeah over the last 200
years it's killed a billion people on
the planet you know most people you
remember from the 1800s died from
tuberculosis this has been a huge killer
of mankind for you know centuries and we
cared a lot about in the 1800s because
it killed us then we figured out how to
fix it for us and now we don't care it
kills 1.4 1.5 million people every year
we know how to fix it we could do so
very cheaply so we find that for about
five billion dollars a year so a trivial
part of what it would cost to do NetZero
or anything else that we're talking
about in climate you could actually save
a million lives every year right now why
aren't we doing that so our point is
simply to say if you did that for every
pound spent you would do the equivalent
of 48 pounds of social good for the
world that's a tremendous bang for your
buck as the Americans would say or uh
you know value back in your past on so
the idea here is simply to say there are
some fantastic things that we can do
right now that would have huge impact so
take for instance nutrition uh there's
way too many people who are still
starving most of it is not because we
don't have enough food but it's because
a lot of people are still poor but one
way we could make sure that more people
would have access to food is to get
better food productivity that's what the
Green Revolution did back in the 1960s
and 70s back then we worried a lot about
you know the whole sort of uh developing
world we worried a lot about India you
know just being a basket case and would
never you know too many people and too
little food kind of thing and then Along
Came Norman bolark whom is criminally
unknown he got the Nobel Peace Prize in
1970. he basically worked with a lot of
researchers to make yields higher they
did so by making dwarf varieties of rice
and wheat and so so they use less energy
on on the stem they just get smaller but
then they can support more of the grain
great it's a simple thing but that
basically saved he's credited with
saving a billion people's lives I mean
imagine having that on your CV that's
pretty good right we should do that
again yeah and that's fairly cheap so
let's invest about again five billion
dollars a year in more research and
development into uh into uh yield
enhancements so that would be both on
wheat and Maize and rice but also of
course on all these varieties that are
that are big in developing countries if
we could do that and get that in the
hands of developing country Farmers they
would be much more productive prices
would fall so everyone would gain and we
would be better fed again if you spend a
dollar there you do 35 dollars worth of
good we're simply saying this is a
fantastic return for the world so we're
coming out with these 12 and I'll bore
you more with them but you know 12
simple policies that could make the
world an amazingly much better place yes
it's not gonna you know suddenly solve
everything and it's not also going to
solve climate change but the point is
this would actually be something we know
works and for very little money could
make an amazing achievement so that's
what I'm trying to push is is we the
Copenhagen consensus cooking time yes
but with lots of researchers so we work
with more than 100 world's uh top
economists and several Nobel laureates
and a lot of organizations obviously on
board on this uh so we have some great
advisors and we're really trying to take
this into global settings so this is
period research getting everybody to
know about it and then again telling
everyone you know all the finance
ministers all the prime ministers to say
if you focus for instance on
tuberculosis or more in agricultural r d
you could have tremendous payback you
could make your country so much better
for very little money wouldn't that be a
good idea and that you know as my my
theory of changes when we give policy
makers these you know 12 great ideas
they're not going to do all of them but
they're going to pay oh I like this one
and and then they're gonna do something
that's really great for Humanity are you
already in conversation with policy
makers oh God yes yes so for instance on
sorry you made me say one more thing so
for uh for Education uh it's you know
one of the big problems in the world we
don't have good education especially in
the developing world uh so about 80 of
all uh uh that go to developing country
schools don't learn what is even
considered minimal information right so
if you ask them a question like this VJ
has a red hat a blue shirt and yellow
socks what color is the Hat
80 of these kids can't answer that
question and you're sort of like oh my
God right that's that's the this is
really terrible the problem is that when
you put a lot of 12 year olds in the
same grade
some of these 12 years have no clue
what's going on and some of them are far
bored because they're way way ahead of
the teacher how are you going to teach a
class like that the point here is and
there's lots of research to show this if
you teach each individual according to
his or her own level you can teach them
much much more now that's really hard to
do in a physical sort of way because
then you need to put six euros and 12
year olds together because they're at
the same level you can do that in some
place and then you you do that but
that's that's hard but you can also do
with a tablet so if you put this kid one
hour a day in front of a tablet with you
know uh this teaching program in their
own language
they will actually this tablet will know
from previous days what level are you at
and teach you at your exact level and
what's amazing about this is so it'll
cost about 25 per kid per year extra
because you need to buy the tablets
we're not giving it to them they're
sharing it with many others right but
you need to have a place you lock it in
you need to have a solar panel to charge
them all that stuff twenty five dollars
but
you will teach them so much
that after one year of school they will
if they will have learned as much as
what they would normally have learned of
three years of school you're simply
making them much better educated and
we're actually working with Malawi
government to extend this to all their
primary schools now uh so you know a
couple million kids so again there's a
lot of great ideas out there and my
point is simply to say why are we so
obsessed with the not very effective
ideas when there's so many incredibly
effective ideas out there now again this
is not going to solve everything for
everyone of course you know it's good
that there are people who are worried
about plastic in the oceans and all
these other things but we need as a
civilization to keep asking that
question look all of this you're
proposing is going to cost money where
can I spend the extra pound or the extra
dollar the extra shelling and do the
most good and I would love for us to do
a little more of that great well on that
note if you're on lombok thank you so
much for taking the time to speak to me
and and show people who found that
fascinating and if they want they I
recommend they read your book false
alarm thank you thank you that's great
[Music]